hi my name's Ginn on the lead car home
design on the racing studio codemasters
and here we're going to introduce you
today the best of British DLC pack so we
all know that McLaren f1 is an awesome
road car this is the GTR designed
endurance racing but a huge wing which
give you massive downfalls in the
corners so it's all about being brave
and attacking those corners at speed you
never thought were possible the weight
distribution is in perfect balance but
really thought about centralizing the
mass to make sure that it can be driven
in a very efficient sort of way and he
asked the mines an awesome vehicle to
start with this is the asta minds at
Gatto special edition the Gatto model
has Body Works style like Italian
designers so get a good a typical Aston
Martin v12 engine very powerful very
torquey for the road if you manage the
weight and the grip and far out of the
corners benefit from all that power
one of the first things that strike you
about my time in SLO it's actually when
you see it you see the sheer scale of
the field and then it goes past and it's
got a huge engineer you know
supercharged v8 engine this sounds like
a an Old World War two Spitfire there's
clearly a lot of power being put out in
v8 and you can really feel that in the
car in our game it is trying to
oversteer and that's due to the amount
waiting car has you talking 1.8 tons of
mass right there spend hours research
and a lot of time behind the patterns d
robot kind of make them as accurate as
possible there's a lot of work that goes
into it to make it feel like that car
because it's taken a handcrafted
approached me with these things we
really care for the gameplay and we want
other people to experience that as well
you